أي دعم مرحب به في أوكرانيا
خاصة إذا بدا مباركًا من قبل
يسوع، يقول هؤلاء الطلاب بدون طيار أقاموا في
كنيسة مهجورة يعملون على
أجهزة المحاكاة الخاصة بهم وأقنعوا قضيتهم بأننا
نفعل كل ما في وسعنا الآن للمقاومة
لأن الروس يريدون قتل الجميع اتصلوا
بنا بهذا  هي إبادة جماعية في
الفصل المجاور للبناء والإصلاح، جنود يوليوس
والقرص والمعلمون، هذا
الجزء بسيط وممتع إلى حد ما، كما تقول وهل
درست الهندسة، ما هو
حالك في الحياة العادية، الاتجاه الصحيح،
أنت كاتب ومخرج سينمائي
والآن  أنت مشغل طائرة بدون طيار، نعم،
لا يُسمح لنا بالكشف عن
الموقع الذي وضعت فيه يوليا والآخرون
النظرية موضع التنفيذ
هنا في هذا المجال غير الضار
مع مسار عوائق بدائي،
قد يكون هذا تقريبًا لعب أطفال ولكن مع
نتائج مميتة بالطبع هذه هي  جميع
الطائرات بدون طيار المدنية التي
يعيد الأوكرانيون استخدامها لمجهودهم الحربي الحالي،
يمكن شراؤها من أرفف المتاجر، لكن
هذا يمثل نقطة تحول في
سلوك Modern Warfare، حيث
يمكن لـ 500 طائرة بدون طيار تم تسليحها تدمير
مركبات وأنظمة أسلحة
تبلغ قيمتها الملايين.
مهندس البرمجيات لوبا  شيبوفيتش بدأت
مبادرة طائرات النصر بدون طيار أكثر
ميزة هي أنها من أكثر
الأسلحة فعالية من حيث التكلفة أه وهي
أيضا سلاح ويمكن استخدامها
لأغراض الاستطلاع أه إذا رأيت العدو يمكنك
ضرب العدو يمكنك الاختباء أه مثل
جنودك لكن العدو يمكنهم رؤيتك أه نعم
إذا كنت أه لا تستخدم التدابير الأمنية
مثل إخفاء إشاراتهم أو تمويهها
لأن الروس يتأقلمون بسرعة،
وتقول إنهم في الغالب يتم تمويلهم جماعيًا
ولديهم صفقات مع الجيش الأوكراني
لتدريب قوات الخطوط الأمامية عشرات من
الآلاف حتى الآن في ما أصبح
استراتيجية لا غنى عنها
والتي كانت مجرد تدريب على إسقاط
زجاجة ماء مملوءة بالرمال،
ولكن قبل بضعة أيام فقط، تقول المجموعة إن
أحد متدربيها السابقين دمر
هذه الدبابة الروسية على الجبهة الشرقية،
ويمكنهم أيضًا القضاء على
مواقع المدفعية و  حاملات الجنود، كم من الوقت
استغرقت لتعلم الطيران، العديد من
هؤلاء الجنود المواطنين هم من النساء يخرقن
الأساطير العنيدة وتوافق يوليا بالطبع
في الواقع على أنها تقوم بتجميع الطائرات بدون طيار التي
يطير بها زوجها أيضًا وقد خاضت الكثير من النساء
هذه المعركة، نحن حقيقيون
الناس ونحن نقاتل من أجل
وجودنا كريستيانا مانبور CNN أوكرانيا
قف